hi I'm Doug ray I'm
teaching staff for the faith and
globalization course and I'm here with
my my good friend Jim Alexander Jim is
an alum of yale college and the harvard
business school and from our point of
view more importantly an alum of enron
he was chief financial officer of Enron
global pipeline and power in the best
known book about the fiasco at Enron he
is described as a fly in the ointment
from the point of view of Ken Lay which
is another way of saying that he behaved
with integrity he went on from Enron
with a start-up known as spinnaker
exploration which later became a public
company and he now lives in in New Haven
near the Yale campus and is a great
friend of the Yale community and welcome
Jim thank you the topic in faith and
globalization today is the relationship
between the the values incorporated in
the best of faith as they relate to the
values expressed in the actuality of
business and Enron of course is a case
study of some importance from that point
of view I agree completely Ken Lay as I
recall was the son of a Baptist minister
well what happened well who knows and of
course faith like anything else has its
layers maybe we could start with how it
is that you found yourself after a
career in investment banking of some
distinction and complexity you found
yourself in Houston
with Enron that's a good question my
last job was with a small New Orleans
firm the CEO of which announced I had a
quote on economic attachment quality
unquote and as I was sort of
straightening my tie in a proud sort of
way Austin I realized this was the most
devastating critique he could deliver of
anyone and while I on camera I won't go
into why we were at odds I decided to
take his advice or his implicit advice
and take my quixotic approach to
business and go off and become a really
it just a consultant to my former
corporate finance clients where I would
be the only person who was not paid by
transactions but just for giving advice
which is a much less lucrative but much
simpler occupation and it also allowed
me to never have any my clients
concerned one whit whether or not my
advice was self-interested which is what
any smart CFO should do when dealing
with investment bankers so how to make
the transition from consultant to
executive another good question um one
of my previous clients had been in run
when I was in an investment banker so I
knew the people at the top very well I
thought and certainly socially well and
so I was called by the chief of staff to
inquire whether I'd be available to do
consulting work for Enron because Enron
got more presentations from more
investment bankers
commercial banks and everyone else under
the Sun you could think of so the chief
of staff really did need help sort of
sorting through all these when I said
fine at second or was a good friend of
mine I said this was this might be
enjoyable enjoyable work and I was I'd
already pledged myself not to frankly
get even with those of my competitors I
felt were congenital liars but actually
they give them some what the benefit of
the doubt when they presented their
ideas so I was actually going to be a
good advisor I felt well a couple of
months after I started and Ron decided
that they really wanted to be able to
take all their international power and
pipeline assets and which largely were
joint venture interests and roll them up
into a company and then sell half the
company little less than half to the
public and end up with a trading entity
which would then also be in a position
to buy future projects from Enron and
that this would be a way to
mark-to-market in a conventionally
acceptable way the the underlying value
they'd build up in their international
assets I consulted on that project as it
turned out for about nine months and
toward the end of it was one of the few
people who had the institutional memory
to know exactly why we had done all that
we had done there was of course there
were many lawyers from Vincent Elkins
who were involved or right from the
start there were of course many
accountants from Arthur Andersen
involved right from the start but in
terms of actual business people there
was only myself or one other person who
was a developer it would had no interest
in being the CFO so folk to me as the
French say they asked me to be CFO under
the pressure of lehman brothers got
arrested soul
and Lehman was very concerned about
conflicts of interests and they wanted
to have a real person being CFO before
they would underwrite them even as a
co-manager underwrite this issue and
their participation was viewed as
important so and run I guess caved and
got a real person and the the minority
shareholders what do we know about them
and why they why they bought in well the
the public bought in first of all this
was going to be have a fairly high yield
as I recall six to eight percent and was
going to have what were described and I
truly believed at the start fairly low
risk assets because it was a series of
operating power plants and pipelines
with contracts offtake contracts or
transportation contracts which made
interruptions of cash flow fluctuations
even in cash flow extremely unlikely
absent a default really on the sovereign
debt and so what you had was a fairly
high yielding equity instrument with
fairly low risk which had some growth
prospects in terms of future
acquisitions so it was typical of the
Enron approach which was to have sir the
high-risk high-return low cash flow as
we all found out assets at the parent
and then hive off low risk high cash
flow assets into various spin-offs which
would then be sold to yield investors oh
the soap at the outset it was a
perfectly sound business proposition
yeah yeah if it were unsound I would
never I would have had misgivings being
a consultant but I never would have
signed on as CFO if I
knew what I ended up learning okay and
can you tell us when the first the first
sense of trouble came to you oh I think
it was probably when Rich kinder and a
bunch of us were flying down to
Argentina a few months after the public
offering we're rich was starting to talk
up it certainly made sense from the
point of view of a seller all the
advantages of the Dominican Republic
power operation and what a wonderful
wonderfully designed wonderfully cited
wonderfully maintained work of art it
was and you know I based upon my own
self perception of representing the
minority shareholders because I was
certain Enron can look after its own
interest and based on undertakings real
implicit but real to the various
investment bankers I was going to be a
real person I started giving the counter
argument which I felt not was not merely
a position but actually the truth and
that was that the Dominican Republic
plan was poorly cited i was going to
start taking some things off i never got
a chance to because really all i got a
chance to say as well from the point of
EPP shareholders and at that point
kinder erupts in fury for maybe 45
minutes me could have been as little as
half an hour but he was only two feet
away from me it was a small jet and so
that's when I started saying this is
it's a strange okay so he saw a
disturbing sign of independent judgment
there in you that yes III think that it
was a conflict of perceptions my
perception was the DPP was a real
company and that if it really was just a
financing techniques that we should have
let people know in the Prospectus
that if it had no independent identity
no independent rationale we should have
said that and if we didn't say it that
we should have normal expectations which
is that the company that sold to the
public will be looking to maximize its
profits and so we had a real conflict I
guess as to our basic perceptions
whether it was a real company or not
okay and it if let's take the story
forward from that point to your
departure from the job well turned out
that it turned out that Enron's approach
was that EPP or what I win fur and ron's
approach would be because of course no
one ever delivered it quite this clearly
is that EPP shareholders should be happy
with whatever the projections are that
the investment bankers have given
regardless of whether or not they end up
paying expenses that really weren't
there is to pay or sacrificing value in
ways favorable than Ron but unfavorable
to the minority so what would happen is
that my immediate boss CEO derived most
of us compensation from Enron would find
it new and always deeply imaginative
ways of having a PP minority pay for
things that were not theirs to pay for
so if you had some incompetent boob
trying to run one of our operations who
chose to resign or leave to have his
deferred comp all of us deferred comp
paid paid for by EPP and of course if
you do the math if Enron owns fifty-one
percent of EPP and let's say the
termination benefits are ten million
dollars and Ron only pays 50 5.1 million
dollars as opposed to paying 10 if if
they pay it themselves so it's obvious
that
as the old dad used to go give it to
Mikey he'll eat anything well give it
today give it the EPP maybe they'll eat
anything so a series of these things
came along where if the actions be
honest if they actually had had someone
wasn't my immediate superior negotiating
with me I'm probably would have spit
split the baby each time because I
really did want to have a workable
relationship with my affiliates but the
process was so tainted by having my
immediate superior the person who turned
my career my bonus negotiating with me
where he represented Enron and I
represented EPP it was all too much so I
had to have a complete victory every
time all they via they didn't handle it
very intelligently okay and so spinnaker
exploration was the next chapter in your
career yes basically i guess i'll add
one Lex thing I altima tlie resigned
along with the general counsel and
controller of EPP at the time that Enron
informed us that as a I think they sort
of cost-saving measures what they said
or maybe is organizational streamlining
I can't quite remember what their their
justification was they were going to
take our entire control group have them
report to Skilling's group and then bill
us back the costs including whatever
bonuses skilling decide to give the
control group I thought that was an
artful gesture and they said okay you've
made it simple okay I'll leave and not
only I left the others the other people
did and the person who replaced me Paula
reeker as CFO spinnaker ultimately
ultimately I guess I can't really turn
state's evidence or or what she was
indicted but I can't remember what
happened to her I don't think she went
to jail I can't remember exactly any
case so i left a PP
and decided to not go back to
conventional Investment Banking for a
while I ran into a very smart guy by the
name of Roger Jarvis who I found
immediately very impressive and we
started looking at the possibility of
starting an energy company Gulf of
Mexico Oread energy company founded on
the presupposition which probably cannot
be mathematically demonstrated but is
but a lot of things in life that are
important can't be that information was
systematically undervalued by the
independent oil and gas sector whether
through excessive self-confidence sort
of macho man orientation to drilling
holes as opposed to looking at squiggles
I have no idea but any case we both
agreed that people seemed much more
ready to drill ten dry holes for ten
million dollars then by 10 million
dollars worth of 3d data and that we
were going to capitalize our company
much more richly with information than
with iron you might say and we worked on
that all of 96 and at the end of the
year started the got our financing in
place over pikkus I was involved Howard
new and of course as a Yale person it
was on their energy side and he was one
of the principal investors along with PG
essay yeah Norwegian 3d seismic company
and got us started and we and the
benefit of having worked at Enron is any
time I was uncertain what we should be
doing I thought what would Enron do and
we did the reverse and
you know it worked like a charm and its
spinnaker was actually very successful
yeah he was it was a very successful how
much of that ends up being luck or
whatever you know it's it gets hard to
say because the with an N of 1 how do
you how do you know but the spinnaker
went public in 1999 it sold out I think
around two thousand five four with
roughly ten to one type of type of
return to the original equity holders
you could argue maybe a bit higher but
at least ten to one so I met you not
long after that when you were in New
Haven as a student at the Yale Divinity
School I yes I i had i retired in two
thousand after I after we almost missed
some quarterly numbers and realizing
that our stock probably would have been
down at least a quarter maybe him a
third in a week if we had missed our
numbers for any reason I had a 48-hour
migraine worrying about whether we're
going to miss them and we don't ended up
not missing them but I said he know it's
a migraine now will be a coronary in 10
years I don't need the money I love the
company but I'm out of here and I had I
guess the way I looked at an unfinished
business from interest i developed in
the bible during during my college
career based upon a course taught by him
and s morgan on the Puritans and so not
certainly nothing having to do with my
upbringing but I developed real interest
and I decided
that if I add the time I was going to go
back and look carefully at some of these
issues so when I retired retired my
figure why not retire to Yale where I
can take classes and go to the div
school where I can concentrate on some
of these lifelong interests and teach
classes as you as you are now with
helping you helping you well and you are
more than little help and we look
forward to a fuller discussion of these
same topics this afternoon with the
students thank you